president has canceled the scheduled
meeting with the prime minister of
Denmark it's been on his calendar for a
while the reason is Greenland the Prime
Minister recently dismissed the idea of
selling Greenland to the United States a
call that quote absurd
so just minutes ago the president
tweeted this quote Denmark is a very
special country with incredible people
but based on Prime Minister's meta
frederickson's comments that she would
have no interest in discussing the
purchase of Greenland I will be
postponing our meeting scheduled in two
weeks for another time the Prime
Minister was able to save a great deal
of expense and effort for both the u.s.
and Denmark by being so direct I thank
her for that and look forward to sorry
scheduling some time in the future end
quote
by the way a deal between the u.s. and
Denmark for new territory would not be
totally unprecedented in 1917 the United
States purchased the US Virgin Islands
from Denmark we'll continue to follow
this story